Adding bling to your
smile isn't anything new,
but one of the buzziest
ways to do it these days
is with tooth gems.
They're small crystals,
diamonds, or charms
that are literally glued to
the enamel of your teeth.
Tooth gems are akin to grills,
popularized by African
American hip-hop artists
in the '80s and '90s.
Celebrities including
Drake, Hailey Bieber,
and Katy Perry seem to love
adding them to their smiles.
We visited Dr. Bobbi Peterson,
who places tooth gems for
celebrities like Justine Skye,
to see how one is placed by
one of her repeat clients.
Jhenelle Hill: I got my first tooth gem
about six months ago.
I love how it blings on
this side, but I'm like,
this side's so empty
that I would love that
when I switch angles,
to have a little bling on this side also.
Bobbi Peterson: This procedure does
not damage your teeth in any way.
This is why I love to do them.
Dr. Bobbi Peterson
always conducts a consultation
to help a client find their
ideal gem and its placement.
Her gems include crystals,
diamonds, and precious metals.
Each one ranges from $50 to $500.
Subtle gems are usually
placed on the canines,
first premolars, and visible teeth below.
For a more noticeable look,
tooth gems are placed on the
central and lateral incisors.
Jhenelle: Now that I'm looking at it,
I think I wanna add one to the right.
The placement process
is pretty straightforward
and takes about five minutes.
First, the tooth is completely isolated
using a retractor and cotton rolls.
After it is cleaned and
dried, an etching solution,
which repairs the tooth's
surface for the glue, is applied.
Once the solution is
wiped and rinsed away,
more air is applied.
The bond to the sealant
is placed onto the tooth
and dried with a UV light.
The glue is squeezed over the sealant,
and the tooth gem is placed using wax.
The gem is adjusted to
a precise placement.
Once the client confirms that
they like the gem's position,
it is cured to the tooth using a UV light,
which takes about one minute.
The gem is polished and good to go.
Peterson: There are no
negative long-term effects
of you wearing the stone,
unless you get your teeth
whitened every month
and your teeth around the
gem are five shades whiter.
It's a little bit harder
to bleach the area
that's underneath the stone.
Jhenelle: I love it.
I thought I wanted it on this side,
but after she, you know, showed
me the placement options,
I definitely wanted it, you know,
right next to the one I originally had.
I am so excited to show
it off to everybody.
I really feel pretty.
Like, I feel gorgeous.